when I was a child every other Friday I
would leave my mother and stepfathers
home an Indian and British atheist
Buddhist agnostic vegetarian new-agey
sometimes Democratic household and I
would go one point four miles to my
father and stepmother's home and enter a
white evangelical Christian conservative
Republican twice a week church-going
meat-eating family it doesn't take a
shrink to explain how I ended up in the
field of conflict resolution whether I
was facilitating dialogues in
Charlottesville or Istanbul or MD bud
the challenge was always the same
despite all odds and with integrity how
do you get people to connect
meaningfully to take risks to be changed
by their experience and I would witness
extraordinarily beautiful electricity in
those rooms and then I would leave those
rooms and attend my everyday gatherings
like all of you a wedding or conference
or a back-to-school picnic and many
would fall flat there was a meaning gap
between these high-intensity conflict
groups and my everyday gatherings now
you could say sure somebody's birthday
party isn't gonna live up to a race
dialogue but that's not what I was
responding to as a facilitator you're
taught to strip everything away and
focus on the interaction between people
whereas everyday hosts focus on getting
the things right the food the flowers
the fish knives and leave the
interaction between people largely to
chance so I began to wonder how we might
change our everyday gatherings to focus
on making meaning by human connection
not obsessing
the canapes and I set out and
interviewed dozens of brave and unusual
hosts an Olympic hockey coach a circus
all a choreographer a rabbi a camp
counselor to better understand what
creates meaningful and even
transformative gatherings and I want to
share with you some of what I learned
today about the new rules of gathering
so when most people plan a gathering
they start with an off-the-rack format
birthday party cake and candles board
meeting one ground table 12 white men
[Laughter]
assuming the purpose is obvious we skip
too quickly to form this not only leads
to dull and repetitive gatherings it
misses a deeper opportunity to actually
address our needs the first step of
creating more meaningful everyday
gatherings is to embrace a specific
disputable purpose and expectant mother
I know was dreading her baby shower
the idea of pinned the diaper on the
baby games and opening gifts felt odd
and irrelevant
so she paused to ask what is the purpose
of a baby shower what is my need at this
moment and she realized it was to
address her fears of her and her
husband's remember that guy transition
to Parenthood and so she asked two
friends to invent a gathering based on
that and so on a sunny afternoon six
women gathered and first to address her
fear of labor she was terrified they
told her stories from her life
to remind her of the characteristics she
already carries bravery wonder faith
surrender that they believed would carry
her and help her in labor as well and as
they spoke they tied a bead and for each
quality into a necklace that they could
that she could wear around her neck in
the delivery room next her husband came
in and they wrote new vows family vows
and spoke them aloud first committing to
keep their marriage central as they
transition to Parenthood but also future
vows to their future son of what
wanted to carry with them from each of
their family lines and what would stop
was this generation then more friends
came along including men for a dinner
party and in lieu of gifts they each
brought a favorite memory from their
childhood to share with the table now
you might be thinking this is a lot for
a baby party baby shower or it's a
little weird or it's a little intimate
good it's specific its disputable it's
specific to them just as you're
gathering should be specific to you the
next step of creating more meaningful
everyday gatherings is to cause good
controversy you may have learned as I
did never to talk about sex politics or
religion at the dinner table it's a good
rule in that it preserves harmony that's
its intention but it strips away a core
ingredient of meaning which is heat
burning relevance the best gatherings
learn to cultivate good controversy by
creating the conditions for it because
human connection is as threatened by
unhealthy peace as by unhealthy conflict
I was once working with an architecture
firm and they were at a crossroads they
had to figure out whether they wanted to
continue to be an architecture firm and
focus on the construction of buildings
or pivot and become the hot new thing a
design firm focusing on beyond the
construction of spaces and there was
real disagreement in the room but you
wouldn't know because no one was
actually speaking out publicly and so we
hosted good controversy after a lunch
break all the architects came back and
we hosted a cage match they walked in we
took one architect put him in a 1:1
corner to represent architecture the
other one to represent design we threw
white towels around their necks stolen
from the bathroom sorry played rocky
music on an iPad got each a Don King
like manager to rev them up and prepare
them with counter arguments and then
basically made them each argue the best
possible argument of each future vision
the norm of politeness was blocking
their progress and we then had everybody
else physically choose aside in front of
their colleagues
and because they were able to actually
show where they stood they broke an
impasse architecture one so that's work
what about a hypothetical tense
Thanksgiving dinner anyone so first ask
the purpose what does this family need
this year
if cultivating good heat is part of it
then try for a night banning opinions
and asking for stories instead choose a
theme related to the underlying conflict
but instead of opinions ask everybody to
share a story from their life and
experience that nobody around the table
has ever heard to difference or to
belonging or to a time I changed my mind
giving people a way into each other
without burning the house down and
finally to create more meaningful
everyday gatherings create a temporary
alternative world through the use of pop
up rules a few years ago I started
noticing invitations coming with a set
of rules kind of boring or controlling
right wrong in this multicultural
intersectional society where more of us
are gathered and raised by people and
wood etiquette unlike our own where we
don't share the etiquette unspoken norms
are trouble whereas pop up rules allow
us to connect meaningfully there
one-time-only constitutions for a
specific purpose so a team dinner where
different generations are gathering and
don't share the same assumptions of
phone etiquette whoever looks at their
phone first foots the bill let's try it
for an entrepreneurial advice circle of
strangers where the hosts don't want
everybody to just listen to the one
venture capitalists in the room knowing
laughs you can't reveal what you do for
a living for a moms dinner where you
want to upend the norms of what women
who also happens to be
mothers talk about when they gather if
you talk about your kids you have to
take a shot that's a real dinner rules
are powerful because they allow us to
temporarily change and harmonize our
behavior and in diverse societies pop up
rules carry special force they allow us
to gather across difference to connect
to make meaning together without having
to be the same when I was a child I
navigated my two worlds by becoming a
chameleon if somebody sneeze in my
mother's home I would say bless you in
my father's god bless you to protect
myself
I hid as so many of us do and it wasn't
until I grew up and through conflict
work that I began to stop hiding and I
realized that gatherings for me at their
best allow us to be among others to be
seen for who we are and to see the way
we gather matters because how we gather
is how we live thank you
[Applause]
[Music]